so at exactly the moment when you need
more information not less
less lying not more
big tech has aligned with intel agencies
to curate everything you learn about the
war being fought in your name in ukraine
and censor anyone who disagrees with
them and the censorship is increasing
senator mark warner has called on his
donors in the tech monopolies to censor
pro-russia social media posts and they
oblige including by americans by the way
and they get to decide what pro-russia
is
meanwhile the television network russia
today which is russia's state media is
being censored all over the world it's
not an endorsement of russia today to
note it might be interesting to know
what the other side is saying it might
be good to have more information not
less glenn greenwald's been making this
point for a long time he's an
independent journalist we're happy to
have him join us tonight
glenn thanks so much for coming on the
censorship seems very open
without apology and it seems more
widespread than maybe i've ever seen it
definitely without any precedent that i
can remember as well i mean you'll
probably recall in the days after 9 11
bill maher when he was at abc was fired
because he said that he doesn't think
the 911 hijackers should be regarded as
cowards that whatever else you want to
say about them it's evil but it takes
courage to fly a plane into a building
and end your life for a cause and there
was a lot of sense even
when we were attacked in the immediate
aftermath that maybe it's not a good
good idea for people to just be fired
because it'll create this atmosphere
where no one can speak it's so much
worse i think one of the things that's
gotten overlooked when we talk about big
tech is how closely aligned they are to
the u.s security state they have huge
contracts the pentagon the cia for cloud
services for all kinds of other services
and so often their censorship is purely
aligned with u.s foreign policy in a way
i think it's quite odious
there used to be the and you grew up in
the united states as i did were roughly
the same age there was this sense when
we were kids that we're americans we can
read whatever we want they had banned
books week at libraries where librarians
fought back against censorship which
didn't really exist when we were kids
what about that idea that as an american
citizen you have a right to read
whatever the hell you want back off what
where is that
yeah so just did for the record i'm
significantly younger than you both i
accept that we're in the same general
generational grouping but
i i mean i i wonder that because you
know one of the first articles i ever
wrote after i got into journalism was
when the british historian david irving
was criminally convicted in austria for
teaching things about the holocaust that
were prohibited namely denialism and i
wrote an article about how all americans
instinctively recoil from that because
we just have embedded within us the view
that government shouldn't be dictating
what we can and can't hear what we can
and can't say
15 years later tucker there's almost
there's very little of that ethos
certainly not as a consensus and i'm so
grateful for the first amendment because
without it i'm certain that we would
have all kinds of laws being enacted
empowering the state not just to ban
ideas but to criminalize them as well
well you'd be in prison like you would
you'd be impr i mean we'd be we'd be
bringing you you know extra underarm
deodorant yeah right without the first
amendment but it seems like they're
getting around it
by just employing their effectively
their agents in the tech monopolies to
crush free speech
one of the things that i think has been
very under noticed is that for the past
18 months with the democrats with their
control in both houses of congress have
repeatedly summoned tech executives to
congress and explicitly said to them if
you don't start censoring more the way
we're telling you to you will suffer
legal and regulatory reprisals and
there's supreme court rulings that say
that of course the first amendment bans
the government from directly censoring
but it also bans the government from
pressuring or coercing private actors to
censor on their behalf and the way the
constitution prohibits and that's
exactly what's been happening and still
is happening ever more so with this war
it's horrifying and you have been one of
the voices fighting back again so we're
grateful for that glenn greenwald
appreciate it
good